i'll wind through this hopefully to give
you enough time to think through what
i'm about to present
to you and it's slightly cruel to give
these to you as starter questions but
you know what
um if you have a look at these two
questions you do actually know
everything you need to at this point in
the course
so hopefully itself as a serves as a
helpful moment to remind you
oh if this is a struggle that means
there's a skill that i need to put more
effort into mastering so let's have a
quick look
at each of these i've begun sorry let me
make it a little bit higher for you
i'm beginning question one by
recognizing i've got some
factors on my denominator here that i
want to break apart i want to use
these partial fractions this partial
fraction idea that we
mentioned very recently you can see
though the particular
original fraction uh that i provided
actually sorry
it's my fault isn't it because i asked
him to open blinds and has made it hard
for you to
can you completely not read that uh i
i was looking at different angles and
read parts of it and i just neglected
this
yeah yeah i completely messed up your
ignorant ignorant integral didn't we
um let us know if it's completely
illegible for you
but you can see given the particular
fraction i started with
because you've got this uh
unfactorizable at least over the real
numbers
this unfactorizable x squared plus 4 it
ends up being one of the denominators
of your partial fractions but because
you have a quadratic denominator here
which you might have noticed from the
handout is our theme for today you end
up with this linear factor
up the top on the numerator when you
have a go through you can see
i've gone through it uh it's sort of a
version of that third
strategy what did mrs lee's call it
divide and conquer i think
you can see i've broken it apart going
back to from this line with all the
fractions in it
i've multiplied through by my entire
left-hand denominator
giving me this set of terms on both
sides and then i choose appropriate
values of
x in order to try and pin down what a
and b and c are so the particular value
that i chose to get rid of b and c
you can see is x equals 2. you see that
x minus 2 factor there
you chuck in x equals 2 everything here
disappears so you just get left with a
times
2 squared plus 4 here's my 4 plus 4 that
gives you a value for a
when i have a look at this next one in
here
because i've got a the value that if i
most easily choose it to get rid of say
b
that i can choose is x equals zero you
see b is attached to that x right there
so if you let x equal zero
b disappears so i already know what a is
b is gone
that just leaves c just right there and
you should get a value of negative one
and then i've kind of done a mix and
match thing here if you want to take us
back to that idea
of masterchef and the mystery box like
yes there are classic things which go
together you can use a pure
cooking technique to prepare a dish but
one of the things about being creative
is you can mix and match different
things so i've decided to go and
for the last one for the last
coefficient which is b i've decided to
equate some coefficients so i noticed
that
on the left hand side how many x squared
terms are there on the left hand side
there are there are none of them in fact
you just have x plus ten right so there
are zero lots of x squared
i know that there's an a x squared right
here and i know what a is
and then i'm going to get even without
expanding i can see i'm going to get a b
x squared over here on the right hand
side so therefore
there's my 0x squared over there that's
a
and there's b so that leaves me with a
value for
b when i evaluate that from there i pop
it back into the original
integral and this is what pans out you
can see there's my a
on x minus two there's my bx plus c on
the other
denominator and then i just need to do
that uh tidying up work
to finish off what's going on down here
got a pair of logs
and then you've got some inverse tan
here which hopefully we recognize
from extension one okay so that's that
let me just quickly walk you through
this derivative right at the very end
here which is going to be one of our
segways
into the final uh this sheet this
worksheet that we're going through
differentiating this log ends up with
well this is my f dash
on f do you see that if i designate this
inside function here f of x
then when you differentiate a log you
get f dash on f
it's not immediately obvious i would say
at least to me anyway
that the most obvious next thing to do
is to pull out a factor
of one on x one of the square root of x
square minus
seven it's not immediately obvious that
that is useful but once you realize
you can get actually if you have a look
here 1 on square root of x squared minus
7
times the square root of x squared minus
7. that gives you the 1. you've got the
original
f dash and then i've taken out that
factor of that denominator there so you
just get left with an x
and if you look carefully i've
highlighted them just to make it obvious
for you
even though they're backwards in order
you've got the same thing appearing on
the numerator denominator that's a
common factor
right so that's why these both go one
two
leaving you with this term whoopsie
daisy down here are you okay with that
following all right uh i do have just
for the sake of it
over here this is me recognizing i'm
just cognitively overloading myself
trying to do this
square root of x squared minus seven try
to work out its derivative
whilst also trying to do all the
differentiation here so that's why i did
it off to the side
got that result and then off i went you
okay with that
happy all right could i turn your
attention to this piece of paper
which some of you have already begun
working on because you can
but before we dig further into it
i just want to explain everything that's
on there and why it leads to an issue
that i'm trying to solve by giving you
this handout
what you have to look at the top of the
page is straight out of syllabus
that m e x that's a code within
nessa's documentation that means this is
a mathematics extension two
uh topic uh the extension one topic is
just called m
e whatever so m e x it's extension two
c one so the c stands for calculus uh
and then further integration is the name
of the topic there's other stuff under
here
um outcomes and all that kind of thing
which you can look up on ness's website
but the particular we often focus on is
the content bit
now i just want you to have a look at
these dot points i want you to think
which ones we have had a look at which
ones we've explored
and which ones we have not yet
have a look at the first one that first
dot point does that sound
familiar what do you think
i'm getting some nods right i would have
called this in fact not i would have i
did call this
unspecified substitution in extension 1
we've looked at finding integrals using
the method of integration by
substitution that's a mouthful for you
but the substitution was already given
to you or always given to you extension
one but you may like to highlight and
i'll do this on my page
you may like to highlight this may not
be given that's the
unspecified part that makes extension to
extension two we'll skip over the second
dot point and return to it shortly
what else do you recognize have a good
third point does that look familiar
0.3 i hope that rings bells because we
literally just used it in the last five
minutes right
decomposing rational functions that's a
function that's the ratio
of two other things decomposing rational
functions are into
partial fractions so that right there
should ring a bell and of course we have
actually if you just carry that on
we have looked at the fourth dot point
two using partial fractions
to integrate functions we kind of did
them all in one hit
now you got three dot points down
beneath which maybe look
less familiar i have i did mention them
in our very first lesson within this
topic
but we haven't addressed them but i
thought you know what for the sake of
completeness i'll put it there
let's return to this second dot point
which as you can see me bolding it and
also
the title of this [ __ ] it's what's going
to be the subject of this
lesson just read it with me right it
says
get the appropriate color here it says
rational functions
involving a quadratic denominator and
then it gives some suggestions for how
we can do this uh and when it says
suggestions there's this wonderful
little phrase there
which uh it's kind of like yeah get out
of jail free card see that little phrase
there
or otherwise uh when i got my job here
uh when i first arrived to your chair
book my job description as headteacher
math said
it listed out all these things and then
it said right at the bottom final dot
point
and other duties as required by the
principal it's like oh great
and anything else mr johnson would like
me to do when you see this phrase here
or otherwise it means completing the
square
is useful but sometimes you have to pull
a few other tricks out of your hat and
that's what we're going to have a look
at
down beneath now we've got sort of six
different kinds
of integrands the things that you
integrate which you can see have some
form of quadratic
denominator now i just want to wind you
back to what my experience of learning
these the first time
was like it's a bit like this
i don't know if anyone remembers when
this switchover happened
uh when i assume several of you use
several of if not all of these apps that
google has
on smartphones i remember seeing the new
icons i can't remember some number of
months or years when they came in
and something not quite right like
sitting with me i was like
i don't like them but i don't know why
like they're obviously nicely designed
and it took someone else some an actual
ux user experience
designer put together this little image
he said well this is the problem right
if you just kind of squint at your phone
and let's be real right you wake up the
middle night if you're like me you're
like
uh i don't know which one's which right
they all kind of look a bit
the same now the first time
people meet integrating this vast
variety excuse me
of functions or rational functions with
quadratic denominators
do they all look a little bit like that
bottom row it's like how am i supposed
to tell these apart okay
some of them are easier to tell apart
than others and what i want to try and
do is
get these thoughts down this is the
important part right the way not to
learn this
is here's the thing and here is the
integral okay and just try and memorize
that
i'm going to tell you right now you will
fail okay because you'll be back in this
situation and you'll just you'll be in
an exam
you'll be under pressure and you're just
russian if you don't understand
if you've got no reason to think i can
work out which one is which
then you're just trying to trust your
memory which under
exam conditions is not the most reliable
thing